[Music]
new wife kind of makes it sound like I
had an old one though I love that you've
got your new tattoo from the wedding
yeah your wedding date on your hand
right yeah she told me I couldn't get a
hand tattoo until after the wedding and
so I got one out of the wedding
for those who might not know Hardy is
The Man Behind Some of country's biggest
hits you have written for everyone Mr
Shelton
FGL Dirks
and I are a lot tighter than people
think I talked to him four or five times
a week
Hardy's duet with Lainey Wilson off his
new half country half Rock album the
Mockingbird and the crow out now is in
the country top 10. and he just kicked
off a new tour so what are your tour
must haves
um
tequila uh whiskey or bourbon Sour Patch
Kids now have you ever tried maybe like
soaking your Sour Patch Kids in alcohol
no but we should do that I caught up
with a 32 year old ACM songwriter of the
year at the iconic Troubadour theater
hard to believe just nearly five years
ago he was here cheering on his buddy
Morgan Wallen we've always shared a lot
of of those uh
Milestones together and it's just really
special I mean in Earnest too and Ernest
has a little guy Morgan has a little guy
do you hope to maybe have a little guy
in the future so they can be their own
little band yes absolutely I I uh I'm
ready now Cali said she wants a couple
years and that's completely fine so yeah
we'll see I just I was like I don't want
all my friends to have like 10 year olds
and we're like over here you know like
rocking the baby
foreign